was a fan in a closet once when i got to
a hotel and they
opened up the closet and they jumped out
and they had a sign and they wanted me
to sign some photographs and i was very
scared and also i thought it was quite
sweet but my security guard was very
upset but
little monsters
hi i'm lady gaga and i will be answering
some questions for lad bible
what's your best party trick making
alcohol disappear
[Laughter]
any particular alcohol
uh
all alcohol any alcohol yeah yeah
whiskey whiskey's my favorite
what song would you choose to get a lady
gaga party started
i would put on the cramps human fly i'm
a human fly and i say buzz buzz buzz
cause it's just because
it's a punk record
what are your top three iconic outfits
you've worn two of the tops have to be
uh both alexander mcqueen
one would be
the outfit that i wore at the end of bad
romance from plato's atlantis his
crescendo collection it was a second to
last collection and then the uh second
would be a garment a piece that he made
for his last collection that wasn't
finished that i wore to the mtv awards
and i went with discharged soldiers from
the military i was trying to make a
statement about don't ask don't tell in
america and wanting it to be repealed
and then i would say that the third
i think the bubble dress
i wore a bubble dress that and i loved
my bubble dress so much and it was
inspired by a dress made by hussein
chilean we had a costume house created
and i loved it because it was it was
whimsical and sweet and who doesn't want
to wear some bubbles
what's your craziest fan story
there was a fan in a closet once when i
got to a hotel and they just
opened up the closet and they jumped out
and they had a sign and they wanted me
to sign some photographs and i was very
scared and also i thought it was quite
sweet but my security guard was very
upset but
little
monsters do you have any irrational
fears or phobias
phobias
like irrational fears
honestly i'm quite afraid of heights i
was really terrified to do the super
bowl to jump off the the roof in america
when i did the super bowl uh but i just
did it anyway just sort of said well
this is happening not a time to freak
out you need to focus
if you weren't a singer and actress what
else would you be doing
i wanted to be a combat journalist when
i was younger and i was also a musician
and also an actor and i ended up going
in that direction i also think my mother
really didn't want me to be a combat
journalist she was terrified she was
sure i think that i would make that
happen for myself i have a lot of
respect for combat journalists so uh
that
who was your first celebrity crush
probably marlon brando
i mean it was when i saw uh
street car named desire
sum up your career in one word
passion
i just think that i have radical passion
for art
it's like my heartbeat
also love
i love to make the public smile
although i continued to work when i took
drugs i didn't make my best work some of
the time i never really um
i never really
wanted to take drugs i just joined in
for the sake of it if i could go back
to when i first saw a line of cocaine i
would say no no